Okay so uh America has research interest
in DNA pattern genome projects okay and
Guy 3 has interest to see its
applicability in comics okay uh
can you also let me okay we have one
more response to decifer the genetic
code to early detection of diseases
that's pretty interesting and Surya
Pratap says I want to know and learn how
data science is working with biomedical
data and how it is so helpful yes it's a
pretty interesting field and I'm sure
that you'll be enjoying a lot from this
program
uh what about the rest of you guys I can
see few of them are still
uh have not shared
can you guys also let me know what your
research interests are
okay so uh adebusola has shared the TSA
researcher and proficient in the use of
SPSS and has just completed omic Queen
production and is working on uterine
fibroid at molecular level and he is
interested in developing knowledge as to
how to apply it to uh his knowledge
based on the omix project training
that's pretty interesting I can see that
a lot of the participants have a diverse
range of interest and are coming from a
diverse range of backgrounds
what about the rest of you guys let me
know in the chat what are your research
interests
also I'm curious to know has everyone
enrolled for the program or are waiting
to enroll
as of yet
okay so Divya has enrolled for the
program that's great and mahanas is a
postdoc in synthetic biology and has a
background in data science
and is here to see if the program is the
best fit for me all right I'm sure that
you'll be able to enjoy a lot from the
mentor he'll be giving you a brief
overview during the first session about
the program as well and it's going to be
an in fact one as well so I'm sure that
you guys will be able to make the most
out of it
and what about the rest of you guys have
you guys enrolled
or are you waiting to get enrolled
all right so meanwhile the participants
are sharing let me start with the
today's session so hello everyone a very
warm greeting to one and all my name is
srigori Krishna Kumar and I would like
to welcome you all for the very first
session on biomedical data science
python so for those of you who have just
joined the program this program will
cover practical and conceptual aspects
of machine learning in application to
high throughput biomedical data using
various tools and typing throughout the
program students will get an
understanding of the opportunities and
limitations of machine learning in the
context of pre-clinical and clinical
research so in today's session
we will cover topics on introduction to
Big Data in bioinformatics introduction
to bioinformatic languages specifically
Python and using the code playground as
well as loading data in Python
so before we begin with today's session
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and Commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the omics logic
training that has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and Regional coordinators that are
helping refine local program Logistics
and adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world
and this training has been completed by
participants in six different
specialization tracks that includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omix data analysis
and students will also have access to
the omix logic resources but how does it
help Advance bi-informatics teaching
omic's logic is important for practical
and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics it takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear part of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omixologic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics
analysis of large data sets and
introduction to basic coding languages
like R and python or even beginning a
data analysis project
and this also comes with an access to
the omix logic courses which include
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multi-omics that makes use of
genomics transcriptomics apigenomics
metagenomics data science that makes use
of bioinformatics using R and python as
well as cheminformatics and example
projects of different fields which you
could learn from and replicate for your
research work
so as a part of the program users will
also be given directions to access the
TT bioinfo platform for bioinformatic
processing and Analysis of data and the
platform includes demo pipelines as well
as data management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run the bioinformatic
pipelines and different stages of
analysis are performed in different
sections on this multi-ohomics platform
so to view the various courses example
projects and student projects you need
to first sign up on the omics logic
learn portal before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
profile on the portal looks like so once
you sign up on the um
portal these are the features that you
need to update on your account that is a
completed profile will have a profile
image full name with appropriate
capitalization link to your social media
handles and a brief bio about yourself
that will consist of your educational
background and research interest
and under the mentors that end under the
activity tab the mentors will be viewing
your progress under the courses tag it
will show you the various courses that
you're currently completing finally
after the completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificate stack so that was all about
signing up on the omaxe logic learn
portal so now let me take you to the
portal and show you how you can sign up
so that you can also take a look at the
various resources that you will be made
use of as a part of the program
so in the chat box I've still the link
to the omics logical and portal when you
click on the link you will see uh such
an interface so I can see that few of
the participants have already enrolled
for the program so and um I'm assuming
that most of you have created a profile
on the portal if not let me show you how
you can so you'll see create an account
option uh just click on that and then
you can enter your name email ID and
password this is one way you can create
an account or you can also create an
account using any of your social media
handles this could be your Google
Facebook app Apple account GitHub
account or even Twitter this is another
way you can look so I'll pause for a
couple of seconds so that the
participants can sign up and if you have
signed up you can simply click on the
login now option and simply click on
sign in so once you have signed up on
Portal please put a yes in the chat box
so that I know I can proceed further
[Music]
okay Manas has signed up
Shay has signed up what about the rest
of you guys
and quickly sign up so that I can show
you the various courses okay my hack has
signed up
Divya has signed up Eugene has signed up
okay so I can see that few participants
have signed up what about the rest of
you guys I'm expecting responses from
rest of the participants
if you have having any technical queries
you can share that in the chat as well
and we'll be happy to guide you
okay so few of them have signed up so
let me quickly
um sign in and show you but uh keep
letting me know about your responses in
the chat box as I'll be monitoring them
as well so once you sign up on the
portal the very first interface that you
will be seeing is the courses page so
here when you scroll down you'll see a
search bar that asks for looking for a
specific course so since most of the
participants are interested in Python we
can simply enter the keyword within and
that will show you the various courses
and example projects that are making use
of the Python uh concept you can browse
through and navigate to your own pace
let's say you're interested in machine
learning
I will also show you the various courses
and example projects so uh feel free to
browse through and navigate at your pace
so for now going to the part where I was
explaining about updating your profile
so that you can simply click on the tab
that says welcome back with your email
ID
so when you click on that tab it will
directly take you to the accounts uh
profile setting page so here you will
see an icon that says profile so once
you click on this you will be asked to
enter your details such as your bio your
name linked any of your social media
accounts so in this case I've linked my
LinkedIn account and my orc ID and I've
also uploaded my profile picture so this
is what a completed profile looks like
as I've shown in my presentation and as
explained previously under the activity
tab the community manager and the
program enter will be tracking your
learning progress it will be displayed
as such and the courses that you are
currently completing will be displayed
under the core system so recently I've
started taking up a transcriptomic
analysis in Python code so that is the
recent course that I'm going through and
once you complete any of your project it
and publish it on our portal it will be
displayed under the project stack and
once you enroll for the program the
program uh will be displayed under the
program stack finally after the
completion of your coursework quizzes
and required assignments you'll be able
to receive the certificates for the
courses that you have been completed so
that was all about
um navigating through the portal and you
can also take a look at the various
student projects under the projects tab
as you can see a diverse range of
students have worked on topics ranging
from oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine neuroscience and so
on we can take a look at those as well
many a few of them have used python
solely for uh data analysis so it will
be giving you ideas as well so that was
all about navigating through the portal
uh so I can see a few queries
um Gayatri will be signing up after the
meeting uh all right and Dr garima is
asking about the free structure yes that
will be explained during the end of
towards the end of the today session
where we'll be explaining about the
program details fee structure and the
scholarships available for the
participants
so if the participants have no other
queries let's move on to the session by
the program Mentor for that I'd like to
invite Dr agwandan Lakshmi Narayan to
start with the today's
session over to yourself
thank you thank you very much recovery
thank you very very much for uh
thank you very much for explaining how
to sign up on how to get get everybody
started with this program let me find
ways to share my screen
[Music]
and confirm that you can see my screen
which we have soon
can you see my screen
I think yeah not yet right yeah wait a
second here
okay
I have to start sharing or start the
slideshow and then hit share button or
else it won't work okay
let's try one more time
yes and now we can see your screen okay
great but terrify so I can follow your
chat
and yeah so if you have any queries we
will uh discuss this whenever you have
this query just put it up in the chat so
when I feel that is relevant we will I
will address them and other queries we
will address in that towards the end of
the meeting
okay
um
so again welcome everybody
when I resize my yeah so again welcome
everybody to the first session of
today's program getting started with
biomedical data science in Python sorry
about that so we will learn for example
today about what constitutes a big data
which is going to be major part of
understanding biomedical data science
right and also in the field of
bioinformatics and why a programming
environment like python or even R is
best suited for these big data analysis
and finally we will also see if we can
get an introduction to
um how omics data data can be loaded
into Python's environment for data
exploration and while going through this
we will also discuss about how different
input data types and structures
uh literally right not uh conceptually
in Python will help us understand the
omics data types and what are the
different ways we can analyze them right
so to proceed
let's begin with what is bioinformatics
and we can Define bioinformatics as a
convergence of biology and data science
where both are actually important as we
will see in next few slides right and in
order to emphasize on the fact who uses
bioinformatics and who is interested in
using bioinformatics as a analytics
method right earlier this answer could
have been anybody from statistics or
anybody that is an engineer or from
computer science background but nowadays
it's more and more biologists and
clinicians are actually trying to use
bioinformatics to Aid their own data to
help their own data to get published to
get succeed and to get successfully
get Publications in in basic and
translational research and Etc so these
uh these events shows us or reveal us
that biology itself is actually rapidly
acquiring the character of data science
it's not like the observational science
that it was done something like 20 years
ago anymore it's more and more of uh
biological questions always start with
what are the big data that we can find
that we can make use of right that will
give us a head start so this is the
context in which we will be using
biological data to understand biology
from that can fuel new research that can
fuel new applications that can also help
you
unearth new questions and if your
analysis methods and Analysis Source or
data are large enough that can be an
independent publication themselves
okay so we have seen that uh we have
discussed that in the previous slide
that biology in today's era is is almost
a data science it's rapidly acquiring
many of the sales is Salient features
and characteristics of the data science
like uh biological data has billions and
billions of data points uh on genes
proteins and other macromolecules and
biological data are usually compiled in
large files and they are systematically
studied right so whenever we have such a
rich data available analyzing this data
will lead to more knowledge and will
lead to understanding generally about
the biology of the living organisms that
can include human health that will also
include crops livestock and general
biotechnology also right okay such
amount of huge volume of data and their
influx actually fuels a lot of
methodologies that can be developed to
understand biology from uh
data driven approach not from a
hypothesis driven approach so what do I
mean by that
so as I mentioned earlier biology used
to be used to begin with hypothesis
hypothesis driven approach right or
observation driven approach you start
with an idea you start with the question
and then you devise a methodology to
measure the necessary parameters to
understand or to have validate that
hypothesis to understand or evaluate
those questions but not anymore now we
the moment that we start to think about
a problem in biology We Gather all the
data that is available we purely go from
data Centric we can also purely go from
a data Centric point of view where we
understand the patterns in the data and
those exploratory analysis that can lead
to much very well defined and much more
uh I mean a very well defined questions
with a much higher resolution than what
we have started with with uh with a
knowledge space or with the known
publication that is going to focus on
few or only part of this data that is
available in the public repository so
that is why we are more and more
resorting to data science and data
analytics methods
data science and data analytics method
to understand biology itself
okay let's
so what is this big data and where do
this big data come from right this field
actually is based on high throughput
Technologies like next Generation
sequencing technology that can generate
billions and billions of data points on
DNA on proteins and other molecules
right and these data points and these
molecules can characterize biological
systems biological phenomena and hence
can be helped to systematically study
understand integrate and establish
trends for many different applications
of in disease oriented studies like
infectious biology in in general
condition understanding oriented studies
like like neurodegenerative diseases or
to study biology of plants and other
microbes like metagenomics that are
focus of how they are involving and how
they are incorporated into our body and
and their symbiotic nature can affect
our help our body or their dysbiotic
results can can be a problem for our
health also
so these are all the different ways in
which big data is shaping up questions
and research approaches in biology and
influence
so
is this data available so the moment
that we spoke about large volumes of
data and humongous data characterizing
many different types and Etc so where is
this data available and is this data
available
and in short yes it is available and we
have been using a sister concern or
sister repository of such data like
um that is based in National Center for
biological inter biotechnology
information
ncba and ncba maintains many such big
data and one of the data that is derived
data that we always
have referred to is the PubMed
database which is a huge database of
many of the Publications
um
focusing on biomedical research right
so
if we take not I mean if we take just
only one part of this ncbi repository
that is gene expression Omnibus which
um which predominantly collects gene
expression data or transcriptomics data
and and
um and
and that transcriptomics data that is
that is uh publicly uh available and
that we can use it for further analysis
also right we can easily count over 80
000 publicly available such data sets in
Geo alone but there are other sources of
data from ncbi
um Under the Umbrella of ncbi itself
that we can refer to like the SRA data
which is uh
[Music]
um
which is going to R which is uh
specifically uh
created and and holds a record of all
the high throughput sequencing
unstructured data right and we can also
refer to ncbi virus in the in the
context of current pandemic
which contains a separate
dashboard or separate sub section for
kovid and coronavirus related
sequence information and derived data so
these are all the different data that we
can refer to throughout the course of
this program and we will keep referring
to that while trying to understand in
what ways python can help us unearth or
relate the
[Music]
trends in this data to understand the
biology basic biology behind it so but
the moment that we say or that we speak
about data right and and
um now you get a chance to focus on the
data itself without the need to uh even
think about the associated biology so we
can speak about data and for example
um
this data can actually fuel developing
different methods of storing and
analyzing data and subsequently
different methods of recording data also
right so that we can effectively extract
very useful information from this so how
do I mean by that for example nowadays
the high throughput sequencing machines
can actually work without any human
intervention at all all you need is to
prepare the library and then let the
machine do its job so that in the end
you will get a digital biological data
and how are these digital biological
data stored and in what format they are
stored and they are available in short
they're all available as unstructured
data so what do I mean by unstructured
data there are some examples of
construction data like audio data image
data like uh I mean mass media post data
reviews on in reviews data these are all
construction and I will demonstrate you
in a short while about the difference
between unstructured and structured data
and we can actually convert these
unstructured data through a series of
analysis bioinformatics analysis right
not this unstructured data but the
biological and structured data that the
sequencer machine is going to give it to
us right we can
use genomics pipeline or transcriptonics
pipeline to convert this unstructured
data into structured data basically a
tabular form of data that can be used
for further Downstream analysis using
any method not only is using python but
you can even use Excel for a small
analysis or for short analysis
um on these structured data so we we
also have some some of the data that is
in between like semi-structured data and
they are Loosely organized into
files folders and uh and
[Music]
um
for example categories that we will also
get get ourselves familiarized with
semi-structured data which is going to
be the structure of downloading data
from
gene expression Omnibus and Etc so to
give you a practical example of these
three different forms of data if I'm
going to ask you a very generic question
what is your educational background
right then you can respond in many
different ways right for example you can
say that as simple as one line answer
like I'm a graduate student or simply
graduate student or you can give a whole
passage of your educational background
and if I go through these answers as a
human being I will be able to understand
and contextualize most of these
information I will not have any
difficulty but when I ask an algorithm
to do this that will be a disaster there
is no uniformity in this data all this
data vary in line
in in total length right in the size in
the length in the volume in whatever way
that you can categorize you can do that
for example
I have a degree in biotechnology and I
have I am a bachelor in Bachelorette or
my undergraduation is focused in
biotechnology can mean the same thing
but for a computer for an algorithm they
can mean two different things they and
it will not
include these two in the same umbrella
so
so what to do in this case right we have
to use algorithms to understand the data
and the trends inside the data but in
the same way we will we we
cannot afford to
um
spend so much time and effort in
taking humans or human health to convert
these unstructured data into a
structured data semi-structured data so
to get around this problem we introduce
structure at the point of data
generation themselves right something
like this so instead of asking a generic
or a descriptive question what is your
educational background I can give you
options so I can give you four different
options
so the moment that we do this we enable
an algorithmic uh
um processing of the in of the data that
I can collect right but now you can see
a problem by comparing what we learned
in the previous slide and what is here
I could not or I cannot cover all
possible options that I can get my hands
onto I can keep increasing the number of
options that I give but
someday or sometime some of the options
that I might keep losing them right so
when we tend to introduce structure in
the data generation process we tend to
lose some information so we should be
prepared for this structuring and
unstructured data will eventually result
in some percentage of loss of some data
so we should think about it also we
should keep this in mind generally so
by forcing structure can actually result
in a reduced amount of information that
we can collect right
to counter that we just keep generating
more or collecting more and more data
right or what we can do is as I
mentioned we can collect unstructured
data or data in unstructured format I
can correct everything like what I see
here this is done as an example in one
of the sessions like this and we even
see some emoticons there so that is how
to process these data then by using a
combination of human
interaction or intervention and
algorithmic study we can force or we can
evaluate or we can actually capture the
structure from the data and then analyze
it and reveal what's inside the data Etc
so of course when we do this we
definitely are going to lose some
information so we don't worry about that
because we can get around that situation
by simply collecting more and more data
or by simply collecting replicates of
such data right so let's let's go uh
let's see what are these what are the
characteristics of what we actually
discussed are shared by biological data
or Big Data biological data right big by
how to say that biological big data
right
so we definitely see that uh three
different ways right now there are five
ways we talk about velocity variability
volume velocity and one more region
right and um these three are very
important among those we see uh of
course yes we see humongous volume of
data that is available and of course we
see that there is huge variability in
the data that we collect right even
between even within a data collection
from one source of uh input like
um a data collection from one country or
data collection from uh even within a
country or state that can that can
result or that can contain humongous
variability in the data right and and
the data actually grows at a at an
exponential rate right the velocity of
data generation is is really
remarkable in biological uh data
Generation by a big data omic data
generation so so to make sense of all
this data what should we do most of
these data is unstructured right that's
what we discussed and to make sense of
unstructured data we have to convert
these unstructured data into structured
data or we have to process it and
prepare for further Downstream analysis
and those processing methods can differ
by the type of data that we are going to
use like for example we can use genomics
data and process it to understand Gene
variance or not Gene variants genomic
variants or difference difference in the
position
difference in the genomic positions
compared to the reference genome that
has been that that is uniformed for all
over all the biological research
concerning genomics data exactly SNP
variance right you will learn about what
what these are in um in introduction to
bioinformatics uh
Associated resource if you go to the
associated resource you can also spend
some more time in in the other areas
where that is going to teach you about
the biology behind what is SNP and what
is SNB and why do we call one and why do
we call not all s and these are smps and
all these information is available there
so let's go forward yes and we can use
for example methylation data to
understand Gene regulation themselves
right and we that Gene regulation can
directly affect the transcriptomics
landscape of a cell we can understand
transcriptomic landscape of a cell or a
sample by analyzing the rnic data right
so these all these different data and
their Associated sequences or sequence
of analysis which is usually called as
pipelines referred to as pipelines or
specific to that specific type of ormix
theta we can extend this to proteomics
metabolism makes metagenomics etcetera
Etc eventually the one common thing in
all of these different kinds of
structuring of omics data is take this
omics data from multiple molecules or
record this homics data from from a
variety of molecules and then subject
them to proper processing algorithms and
proper processing Pipelines
convert these unstructured data into
structured data or a table which we can
use for for the downstream analysis
okay so we can either record our own
data and do whatever that we have
discussed in the previous studies or we
can use the power or we can use the
humongous volume of unstructured data
that is stored in the public
repositories to come up with our own
method of structuring data that is that
we believe is going to be extremely
suited to answer or to focus on the
hypothesis or a question that we are
generating okay so if we look at the
discrepancy between the amount of
unstructured data and structured data
available there is still scope for all
of us to
excellently structure our carrier around
this unstructured data itself so feel
free to
explore more of this unstructured data
and and come up with different
techniques with which we can understand
the basic biology behind this data so
what can we do for example this is an
example
um
uh of how a sequence pipeline can
actually work in our favor right so we
take the raw data raw unstructured data
which is usually stored in fastq file
format and this first queue file format
that stores the raw data will contain
short reads or short stretches of
sequences that are sequenced by the
sequencer machine
and these short reads can actually be
aligned to their respective positions in
the in the frame of reference genome
right and these reads and the reference
genome can come from a different variety
of different organisms if we want to
focus on SARS then we can use a source
scope to sample and Source scope to a
reference if you want to study human
related condition then we can take the
sample from the from the from the
disease or altered sample and then
perform this analysis to understand what
are the positions that are different in
the deceased state of the sample
compared to the reference genome so how
typically how will we do this we take
the raw fuscii files and then we subject
that to a pipeline or genomics pipeline
or simply DNA variant calling Pipeline
and in the end we get a variant calling
file or VCF file or a table of mutations
this is how we actually structure our
pipeline analysis pipeline in the a big
data bioinformatics server that you will
have access to once you get registered
into this program
okay but how to do that and everything
all this information is available in the
learn portal but that is not going to be
the focus of our uh program in this
program so what will be the focus of our
program so this is this is I want to
sidestep this will explain what a
variant is when you align the short
stretches of sequence against the
reference genome you can identify the
differences like this right like this is
this position is different at this
position so this is how we collect the
variant at each and every position of
the of our samples genome compared to
the reference genome so when you collect
all of this we can tabulate them look at
this tablet them and based on their
impact we can generate a somatic score
this is an example of a mutability index
pipeline that one can run to understand
and the importance of mutation at
different positions in your disease
sample or in your tumor sample compared
to the normal sample that you have also
provided so in for example generally in
cancer biology these non-matches like
the one that I have marked here or
highlighted here which contains maximum
somatics course are actually
analyzed for their
mutational status or analyzed for the
impact analyzed for the to understand
how they might affect important genes
that are involved in the tumor growth
and tumor disease progression etcetera
etcetera so to uh to do this we can
actually yeah
take this data right and then for each
and every position we can generate
something like this somatic score and
this somatic score okay it's going up
okay this uh
tabular information we can subject the
two different kinds of analysis in
Python's environment to understand which
positions are extremely important or
which positions are statistically
relevant compared to the other positions
in the same list right this kind of
analysis you can do with python by by
simply applying some different kinds of
Statistics in this
in this form of tabular data so this is
one way of analyzing genomics data to
understand their impact so
we can now shift our Focus to
transcriptomics data and such a data
actually transcriptomics data represents
the MRNA expression which is excellent
way to analyze what is going on inside
the cell right because it actually
observes active transcription of protein
coding uh inside the cell and this
protein coding can be variant or can
vary depending upon the condition of the
cell and they can have for example
different ways of mixing and matching
these exons to produce different ISO
forms of these proteins and there are
studies which tells us or which shows us
the number of isoforms increase with the
condition of the disease or altered
condition of the cell for example in
cancer right yeah so that so that we can
understand the impact not only the
impact of these variants of these genes
in a quantitative manner but also we can
subject that to several different
analysis to understand
ah not only this Gene and several other
genes is impact in a much a much
different fashion also right in a
variety of different ways so in order to
do that we have to again run a basic
pipeline like this which will involve
taking the first few files and running
through several steps of several process
of algorithmic analysis in the end we
will reach this an expression table
right so this is a table that we will
use many different times many many uh
many times in the in the program
um simply because they are very
intuitive to work with and also RNA seek
data or expression table is the most
used omics data right in in biological
research or in any uh yeah
um
automatic automated analysis of existing
data or publicly available data right so
what does this table tell us unlike the
genomics data this tells us
for each and every G and for different
sample the
expression level Quantified by different
normalization procedures and what are
these normalization procedures and how
will they impact you have all this
information in the learn portal but
generally to give you an idea this
normalization or any form of
normalization even for that matter
z-score normalization will help us
compare the expression levels of one
gene compared to the other Gene within
the sample across the sample and also
between the samples right lot of these
things can happen when we normalize the
data okay so that is one way to proceed
and then
another form of data actually and the
type of data that we can definitely
discuss throughout the course of this
program is metagenomics data so unlike
the genomics data and transcriptomics
data that you just heard which will come
from only one type of organizing
organism right if you are doing this
analysis for a model system like mouse
or or a virus like SARS then you will
get a transcriptomics and genomics data
just from SARS or this mouse or from
Human for that set but metagenomics data
is actually completely different because
we are looking at a sample that can
contain millions and millions of
microorganisms and we are actually
taking those microorganisms genomes and
then trying to quantify uh by number or
identify the population of these
microorganisms in the sample that we are
discussing or that we are concerned with
and that can be related right the
quantification of this microorganisms
can lead lead to understanding of how
these Quantified microbes are
for example abundant in some some
altered state of the altered state of
the sample and and very balanced in some
other state of the sample so this will
straight away lead us to understand
their role in our inside our body and
such an analysis is implicated in a
variety of different situations like
um uh from from normal obesity and even
from normal digestive related issues to
all the way up to neurodegenerative
diseases well it can affect completely
different part of our body and these are
all very interesting also and and they
are so they are fast
they are growing so so fast that I I
think we can easily predict in in
another three to five years metagenomics
data will become the most analyzed data
compared to transcriptome Etc so it's
very interesting if you are interested
in working with such data please
check some Associated resources and also
we have some programs coming up focusing
on this data analysis a lot so this is
this is a pipeline which actually
analyzes again the first few files this
time not from one from the sample yes
but not from one organism but from
several different organisms and such a
data comes with its own complications as
well and we get around these
complications in the library preparation
process Itself by focusing on one gene
or and the at the level of uh quantity
at the level of a downstream analysis
where we again can focus on one specific
um gene or one specific species
depending upon the kind of data that you
have but mostly this 16s amplicon
sequencing data is what is used widely
in metagen of in metagenomic studies and
that will give you uh the quantification
or abundance of these different microbes
right a variety of different microbes
present in the sample and when we take
the sample for for example an altered
state of the cell compared to the normal
state of the cell we can understand the
impact of the abundance levels of these
microbes in those samples and hence how
they interfere with our biology in a
very
helpful way and also in a very hindering
way so this data can actually give rise
to uh yeah this abundance plot obviously
you can plot and analyze their
relationship but
in the end what will you get again we
will get a structured table like this
unlike the transcriptomics data instead
of genes or the genes that are
collected in as rows we have operational
taxonomic units that are collected as
rows and their abundance levels are
recorded across different samples and
what are these otus in short these otus
are or they can be annotated to one
particular species or genus of bacteria
sometimes these otus are so specific
they can go this annotation can go all
the way up to species and strain related
information and sometimes uh due to the
specificity or due to the availability
of the characterized data they can stop
at different taxonomic ranks so these
these things right unlike the other
structured data output for metagenomics
we will get two outputs right one for
quantifying these otus and second one
for annotating these otus
this is what we will get so the
discussion so our analysis can actually
consider at what level or at what
taxonomic rank do we want to combine
analyze and identify the trends within
this metagenomics data using different
platforms right using r or python
whatever platform that you want to use
you can use in the end this is a
structured data and you can use several
different analysis methods to understand
the patterns behind it sentence behind
us
so what will we do right what what how
do should we start and what will we do
from all of these structured data we can
do everything that is listed here right
of course we are starting with getting
started with bioinformatics in Python
and then uh yeah some of this should
change and we can for example process
data data wrangling subject this to data
wrangling visualization and and the
processing of this uh of this data we
can use Advanced visualization option to
understand the segregation of sample
based on the data for example we can
perform simple statistics analysis we
can perform Advanced statistical
analysis like machine learning Etc all
of these are covered in this
program so how are we going to do that
right if we want to work with python we
have to understand how python can be
accessed using different methods because
some of these methods can work for some
of you while some might not work for the
other we can first excuse me
there are three modes of working with
the codes that we will deal with the
with uh
with the code blocks in this program and
also in the associated resources you can
for example study and practice in the
lesson themselves right that I will
demonstrate you today and or you can
study the codes in the lesson and then
apply it to your own python interactive
development environment that you have
installed in your computer or you can
study the code in the learn portal or in
the lesson and then apply it to a
shareable jupyter notebook kind of
environment like Google collab and Etc
each one of these method has their own
advantages and limitations if you want
to keep in one window then I prefer you
to work with the
learn portals tools which I will explain
how you can do that right and if you
want to if you do not want to keep
installing modules and libraries again
and again I can suggest you to install
Python and python Visual Studio code
code and install the necessary modules
once and be dealt with that and for
example if you want to share your data
with us and get our feedback on your
assignments on your practice then Google
collab is the perfect way to do that
right okay
so
um
how are these data interpreted inside
inside Python's environment right any
programming environment has its own
strength in a way at which it is going
to organize the data and how are we
going to exploit that organization to
load our data into what format so that
we can maximize information without much
needing or without
much I mean or without required or
necessary necessary pre-processing done
outside the Python's environment right
so python has a different way of storing
data this is common to Python and R
which is of two modern languages or
modern scripting languages right python
can store your data in One Direction and
that is called the series or vector it's
called a series in Python it's called a
vector in R and python can store it in
two Dimensions that is Matrix and it can
store it in three dimension those are
arrays RH can also be two dimensional
though so these names can be used
interchangeable but what is the one
thing that you observe between these
three different data types
all of these data types are colored in
one uniform color so what do they
represent they represent that the series
or Matrix or array they can take data of
only one data type if the data is has to
be stored as a series or a vector or a
matrix or an array all of the data has
to be in the same data type right you
cannot have for example situation like
this where this column is uh
[Music]
is character and these columns are
numerical or float right and we can have
in biological data a variety of
different combinations of this we can
have a column uh that is that tells
which sample or which Gene that this
data is from we can have a column that
also tells for example
um some other information categorical
information like whether this Gene has
mutation or not that can be a logical
column also yes or no can also be happen
and also we can have some other
categorical information like uh do we
have do we see treatment response for
these samples right so these
different data types in one table right
can be easily loaded into an object
called Data frame right this is this is
this is a re working or restructuring of
a tabular format that is in some old
languages and the script
script string languages right and data
frame is the best way to load omic
structured data because it accommodates
everything and it also enables
processing in such a way that we don't
lose information we can extract
information through multiple different
methods we can subject data frame
themselves to statistical analysis and
we can convert data frame into different
types as required by some of these
analysis and eventually in the end you
will come across something like this a
list which is just a collection of bunch
of these objects so that we don't have
to
we don't have to confine to the
requirements of loading data into a data
frame object or into Vector a matrix RNA
for example data frame can be of
different colors but they have to be of
equal length you cannot have a differing
length in any direction for data frame
right at least in the horizontal
Direction this can be accommodated by
including an n a value but all of them
has to have same length or same number
of entries
so that is some of the restrictions or
some of the requirements of loading
these into different data structures in
Python but list does not have that we
don't use list a lot but for some
packages and modules they use
data and analysis results and different
forms of output into lists from which we
can easily access different of different
components of the list to understand
what we have done so far so this is how
we will this is how we will load the
data into and interact with the data and
this is an example of how we can test
ourselves in the learn portal right and
this is the code you can call this as a
code playground and you can call this as
a challenge platform so what it does is
it gives some instructions for you to
try here this is an editable code
playground and you can edit and then run
python and code and the results are
going to come up here like this right we
have several of this control we have a
place where you can drop a file so that
that file can be accessed in this in
this code area and once you have learned
the code in the learn the code section
literally like this and you can come
here and practice in the test your
knowledge or practice your code area
section right
we have inline commands to direct you
and we have places where you can run
your code or we can you can type your
code and this will have simple
challenges like uh as simple as we would
have left some part of the code
intentionally so that you can complete
and then test your understanding of this
code for loading data and etc etc right
and this this code involves loading a
file this is where you could drop a file
and we will give a link for the file up
above this code area code breakdown and
you can for example refresh reload this
part and for example you can copy this
code so that you can paste it in ide or
this thing
collab environment for example you can
get load packages and Etc loaded
packages here and you can stop the
execution you can refresh the whole
status of the Python code playground
here and for example if you run this
so how to do this will be explained in
learn the code section and the learn the
code section will look like this right
what do we learn from here we have
blocks of explaining what needs to be
done to the data using which function
and using which option and we have
blocks of code explaining or showing you
how to do that right this is exactly the
block of code that you will be using to
execute in different ideas and different
environments that suits you right this
is this we call learn the code section
where it is structured like this and any
output from the code is also printed
here so that you can compare your output
with the output that we have pasted so
that you are not lost in trying to
understand so for this purpose we will
use standard tools and standard
attributes functions like finding out
the size of the data finding out the
dimensions of the data finding out what
are the type of elements that we have in
the data for example what are the data
types like character integer float
categorical logical
etc for example
we can find how many different ways or
what are the ways that will help us
select only part of the data for example
we can use this option to select only
one column or this option to select
another column so when to use this and
when to use this can actually form a can
actually depend upon type of codes that
you are writing sometimes we can use
this and sometimes we can use this
depending upon what how the output is
going to be generated and
what can follow after this right that
that's also depends on that is also a
very generic way of using numbers to
extract information like a column or a
row that can be very useful when you are
including these um
this type of extraction inside a loop
okay so that's what we will do and we
will use some specific functions and
attributes that can interact with the
data frame for example we can get the
statistical summary of the data frame we
can get the first few lines and last few
lines of the data frame to check whether
it is loaded perfectly or not right so
so how are these coding challenge used
something like this from here and here
these are the example coding challenge
this is where we let you for example
load the important modules right so that
you can load it in the environment
Python's environment and then this is an
example of a coding challenge where we
say okay you can find the file link here
right click on it save the file onto
your computer and then drag the file and
drop it here so once you drop it here
you will look at or you will observe
that the file is loaded into this code
playground and then the code Codes
inside this code block can actually
access the file by just calling by their
name and once um this is a solved puzzle
once you have completed solving this
puzzle you will see on screen output
here then if this is successful then you
will see success in running the code and
if you if you make a mistake and it will
say try again right that way you can try
solving these core challenges and then
test your knowledge of how you have
learned this code so far okay
let's go quickly we are a little bit
behind so this is just a beginning first
two sessions are going to be like this
and I mean not even first two sessions
even in the next session you are going
to get your hands on to some of the demo
collabs that we have prepared for you so
that you can follow along in the next
few sessions so these demo co-labs what
will they do they will take the codes
from learn the code section as we have
given here right they will take the code
from here and then put it into the
collab and show you how to
um
execute that that is it I actually
forgot where is it yeah how to execute
this so that's how this is actually done
like this we take the code and we run it
we discuss the output in each and every
uh code so that's how it is done so so
that you understand what sort of
analysis is done and this is done in an
interactive way where you can follow
along while I am working on this code
blocks and then check these outputs and
you will also be brief that these videos
session videos are available for
asynchronous viewing and practicing also
okay well this we will skip we already
have seen this
so yeah this week with this also I will
skip I will see this so
how are these studies used right for
example such an analysis is what is used
in this study which actually records
Comics data of seven different types and
Drug response data for the patient
derived cell lines for 90 different
drugs so by expertly combining these two
structured data they can come up with
several different methods with which
they can identify which method works
best to predict the treatment response
of these different cell lines and what
omics data contributed to the positive
collection or to the utmost accurate
prediction of this of the treatment
response from these cell lines that's
what the kind of study that you can also
develop and generate once you have once
you have gone through this program so
let's quickly go through this we will
learn little bit more and I quickly want
to jump to the last slide where I'm
going to show you for example if you
want to
incorporate a data science and data
analytics using python into this
environment this is a typical flow that
you will go through for example you will
think that you are going to spend lot of
time in this data analysis path but in
fact you are going to spend a lot of
time in cleaning up the data in the
exploratory data analysis that's going
to shape up the kind of analysis that
you will run here so that is what you
will experience by the end of this
program right if we take for example a
machine learning analysis that involves
the random Forest uh algorithm the
actual algorithm that runs or that
predicts and that generates model can be
summarized into four lines but the data
preparation but the sample preparation
data cleaning tidy up the data the
initial visualization that helps us
understanding the patterns in the data
that can easily take up anywhere between
50 to 70 lines of code so
uh you we don't need so much of code
because we have curated many of these
data and then that can be summarized
into let's say 10 10 to 15 or maximum 20
lines of course something like that but
in reality when you are going to develop
your own method my power my point is you
are going to spend lot of time in these
areas in data processing and explorative
data analysis so that you can
narrow down on the perfect and data
analytics method that you want to apply
and when you apply boom you will get
perfect results are very impactful
results that you can gain from so with
that I can conclude today's session and
I have covered most of this and if you
have any queries type it out in the chat
and if not I'm going to pass it on back
to sugary or sonalika who is going to be
yeah who is going to discuss some of the
uh programmed related
syllabus and where to access what and
registration process also uh in short
yes Niha machine learning is going to be
covered and we have something like five
or six different sessions focusing on
machine learning in fact the third
session will start with the basic
machine learning introduction to machine
learning and you will be up and running
by fourth or fifth session with machine
learning in Python okay
okay I will hand it over back to sigouri
yes thank you so much so now to uh cover
the program details and registration I
would like to pass on stage to shubham
yeah thank you so much
hello everyone uh I'm shubham Kumar I'm
the business development and marketing
associate here at Pine biotech
so today I'll be covering your
registration part for the program so
could you confirm is my screen is
visible
yes
all right so as you can see that this is
a program page for biomedical data
science in Python in which you will be
learning about the statistical analysis
data visualization and machine learning
and here you can find the date like it
will be commencing from 20th Jan today
was the first session
so I just scroll down more you will find
the program overview here uh what you
can see is the summarized part of the
program which you will be learning about
various topics and Concepts like machine
learning the for clinical and
pre-clinical researches then you will
get to see about the some of the project
examples from an omics logic loan
platform
so yeah like yes and when you scroll
down or more you will find an um
interactive session of syllabus for the
interactive sessions and in calendar
where some of the dates are highlighted
so as you can see uh 28 Jan which is two
days highlighted on that particular day
we will be covering your all sessions so
today as we have conducted a first
session and on the right side you can
see the topics to be covered like
introduction to the program and
objectives
and next session which will be conducted
uh conducting will be on 24th Jan and we
will be covering the data processing and
exploratory analysis part and here you
can see the various dates and the topics
which we'll be covering
so coming down more
um you can see that uh we have three
different 10 years for this program
so one is for 45 days 60 days and 90
days
so the common resources for the uh all
these tenures is online tutorials uh you
will get along with that as I have
earlier mentioned you will get the
access for the project examples then you
will get the access of the cloud
pipeline for from the um we have a table
server cloud based uh server so you can
get the access of that to run your
pipelines along with that as Sir has
mentioned when you get the coding
sessions and by chance if you miss any
of these sessions then we'll also
provide you with the session recordings
along the online mentor and technical
support and yes of the completion of the
standard will get a certification of
completion so the difference between
these tenure is for 60 days you can see
uh like we have an extra uh like
resources that is one-on-one mental
support we'll be providing you and in
the 90 days uh you will get along with
the one-on-one mentorship you will get
an extra time to work on a project let's
see if you have any project idea or
research project idea so you can cover
on the 90 day standard and you will also
get a chance to publish also and after
that yes uh the certification of
completion and certificate of excellence
will be providing you
coming to the uh phase or the price so
as you can see uh here the price is in
USD so uh for 45 days it is 150 for 60
days it is 300 and for 90 days like it
is 450. so let's say if someone is from
India so here you can find on the top
right on drop down menu where you can
just simply click your currency from the
place where you are residing then for
the INR the prices are 7 500 then for 60
days it's nine triple nine and for 90
days it's 14 triple nine
so
um like and how to proceed with this uh
do you simply have to click on this uh
buy now button and fill up your details
and yes uh let me have several coupons
for uh low income countries like African
Nigerians and as well as for PhD
Scholars also we have some scholarships
so we'll provide you with that coupon
code you can simply enter a coupon code
here and after that uh click on this
checkbox and select a payment method
so this is your complete uh registration
part or the enrollment part for this
program biomedical data science in
Python I'll share you the link of this
so that you can go through this after
the session
yeah so if you have any queries related
to this please feel free to ask
can the duration of course be extended
later say after 45 days to 60 days by
paying difference in a month yeah of
course you can extend your program so if
you are enrolling for 45 days and you
want to enroll for 60 days then you can
pay the difference already so how much
scholarship is available for PhD
Scholars uh hello you can uh like please
mention your email ID so that we can
share the details about the scholarships
where I made
or you can simply contact us at
yeah thank you Mr gauri so she has um uh
given you the contact details so you can
mail us at marketing logic.com or uh we
have about a number active on WhatsApp
that is
98761-34120 so you can do the clipping
us on WhatsApp also
is this course will get you a job
um not exactly we can guarantee you uh
the job part but uh yes you can add this
uh certification and the experience in
your CV so that it will uh like uh
enhance your CV as well
and if you uh like our mentors will be
uh guiding about the openings also
so yes uh like you can uh there are
chances you can get the job but we
cannot guarantee that
I mean in chart can I chime in we don't
provide placements regard with okay yes
so what we what we provide is Excellence
you go through the program you will get
excellent guidance and excellent
mentorship for trying to for using
python related analytics on biological
data that itself is a very sought out
skill set in today's bioinformatics
world so if you
advertise that you have completed this
course and you are an expert in using
python to understand uh omics data and
you are doing a project in this that is
going to amplify the visibility of your
visibility among your competitors in
this particular field so that is that is
how we provide opportunity for to help
with the job place not placements to job
opportunities we have a page which lists
the available jobs that we can get hold
on right we have a team which is working
on yeah exactly for curating these job
lists that are useful and that will be
um that that yeah that are very um
relevant to bioinformatics and
computational biology
[Music]
applications so you can refer to that
and and learn if some of them are
um
[Music]
some of them are applicable to you you
can apply to that right and and if you
for example work with us for your tenure
of for extending this program into a
research Fellowship internship or
research fellowship program that will
make you work with us for three more
months in which you can get a research
project done that you can publish in
learn the learn portal or learn nomix
logic portal you can first of all share
your project with your uh in in part of
your CV and in the applications that
people can go through your projects like
the students projects that srigori was
talking about and two if you have uh if
you have done excellent research then
you have possibility of extending that
research to a paper right that is also
possible
and and what can this give you this
gives you valuable time with us and it
gives us opportunity to understand you
so we can be part of your recommendation
and reference letters also because in
the past people have asked us or people
have consulted us to
um
provide them recommendation with and of
course in variety of different places if
you get a recommendation letter from a
from a place where you have done a
project where you have worked on a
project that adds to your value so these
things will help you in finding a job
and in in application towards the job
and Etc right
thank you so much sir
uh we have one more query from Niha
are they free available alternatives to
T bio platform that can be used after
course completion uh like that that
could be freely available Alternatives
but we're not going to discuss that you
are uh
it's not ethical to discuss an
alternative to a program that we are
selling inside this sales pitch of the
program right but anything free is not
going to come as free right you have to
work on that and the other platforms
have certain limitations and
restrictions that Tio info platform does
not have none of the none of the other
platforms either paid or free have the
flexibility of the T bioinfo platform
that I can say with the 10 years of
experience in omics logic or omics
related research right and none of the
other platforms also have the
interactive interactive aspect of the
outputs that you can get your hands on
right and of course most importantly
none of the other platforms have the 24
7 support the tibio info platform and
find biotech gives to right we of course
check your inputs and check your support
24 7 and some of us are placed in some
of us are based in us and some of us are
based in in India so we cover most of
the time zone and we will get back to
you within 24 hours with the solution to
whatever query that you are throwing at
us so that is what makes T bio info
platform and the find biotech and learn
portal very unique
amidst the competitors I may say other
options that you have around uh you to
learn this particular skill set okay
so there is a payment related question
we can answer that
yeah I think
yeah thank you so I think uh Spurs uh
would uh clearly uh tell about the
additional payment part or you can uh
mail us your you can give us your mail
ID we can share with the details for
that uh yes shubham exactly
also
uh sorry for the wrong pronunciation if
I am doing after 90 days we do inter
three months any additional payments so
uh I'm unable to understand your
question but I am guessing it if you're
interesting in turn three months in turn
okay okay
so uh after 90 uh days like for 90 days
you will go through with the modules
which we have mentioned and um
shubham has showed you a glimpse of the
modules which are there in the program
page after you uh gain those conceptual
as well as Hands-On and Hands-On
practice of these modules you can
definitely we can definitely you can
send your CV to us we can uh like there
is a proper protocol which we follow for
the internship part and after going
through with your CV we will be mailing
you out the steps of the internship and
the pre-interview process so definitely
uh you can do internship with us in our
company as well
is something different
are you America are you asking about the
research internship or the search
Fellowship uh that we were talking about
or are you seeking internship position
yeah exactly so the research program
research internship program is a
separate program all together yes yes
yes that's yeah yes uh basically uh in
night I'll I'll just briefly tell you in
90 days tenure if you could see on the
screen
uh they you will be having 45 days of
training and the rest 45 days would be
devoted to your independent research
project
so in 90 days tenure you will get both
the opportunities but if you if your
project work is incomplete and you still
want to continue and get it done and
also work on your project for the
publication part also then yes there are
separate additional charges for it and
according to the tenure or uh callular
timeline
how how much you will enroll for example
for one month extra you are enrolling or
two months or 45 days we'll uh we'll
charge you accordingly the fee is
accordingly
so uh yes there is additional charges to
it does this course cover Cloud genomics
what is cloud genomics
if genomics analysis done over the cloud
right if that is the case that is what
is actually
um three bioinfo servers doing
yes kind of but you will not get to set
up anything there
right we have set up everything in the
server you will access the server
through the front-end website
so that is what is going to cover this
is not a course to
help you with setting up the analysis
platform but this is a course that will
help you to understand the logic behind
um How would how we can apply these
different methods to our mix data yeah
so of course Cloud cloud-based genomics
data analysis economics data analysis
you have to work on setting it up in I
think in environment that you are
referring to is um
AWS and other ones others correct
at AWS and Azure something like that
yeah exactly yeah so
um those are all options that we do not
cover unfortunately here and uh exactly
yeah gcp yeah exactly
but what I can assure you is
you will plan or you you can learn how
to compare different analysis methods
from our course so that that can give
you Clarity in what to install and how
to get get this done within AWS and
other options unfortunately we don't
cover that in this this program
thank you so much so does anyone have
any further queries
if so we'll be ending today's meeting
all right then if no one has any further
queries uh thank you so much everyone
for joining today's session and for
those of you who are not uh enrolled for
the program yet I hope to see you all
for the uh next session as well and with
that thank you everyone for joining and
have a great day thank you